my name is Turner shaky and I'm from
Cape [ __ ] and 39 year old and I
McIver and I've been carving all my life
since I was 10 euro
I learn how I learned by watching my
grandfather that he used to carve I used
to sit beside him when he used to work
on this carbon and for you as you got
older what kind of things did you like
to carve I I like doing different
carvings than doing the same thing all
the time and sometimes I just followed
the shape of the stone and try not
wasted too much Wow so what do you mean
you can see a you can see a stone and
you can see an image in the stone even
before you start yes not not all the
time but that's usually happens and what
kind of stone do you work with the most
I mostly work with the college
serpentine soapstone tell us a little
bit about your sculptures that are just
here home or your carvings excuse me yes
these carbons I like doing faces that my
grandfather used to make just the faces
but the idea came came that if I do any
more work than then the face adding a
wince with a feat how long would it take
you to carve something like we're seeing
just here beside you this one this kind
of peace it takes four to five days to
finish it up from this time how do you
feel when you're carving something like
that and how do you feel when you're
done when they're done I look I take a
closer look
when I take a closer look when I look
like mucronata the details i think i
have to work a little more but when it's
completely done I feel relief and this
because it is tiring work hard work and
do you use a machine or tools yeah today
yeah mostly power tools grinder and die
grinder and other small power tools but
I mostly use die grinder and a grinder
angle grinder and I hand tools like
chisels or hand files I really used to
like the hand tools that but it takes a
little longer to finish up and the power
tools are much prettier quicker today
and much more easier to figure the stone
with power tools what would you say to
your kids if they want to be a carver
like you were an artist will you
encourage them or will you discourage
them yeah i would encourage them but i
would love to see them finishing the
screw first because i never finished the
school it will be more important if they
finish school that they they would not
having a hard time split speaking or
talking English like like I am cape
dorset is famous for the the prince and
the annual print collection do you feel
like the carving should be getting more
attention than they are I was we the car
was need more
more attention than rushing today test
11 especially today young cars are doing
rushing work even though we encourage
them to take their time if we look ahead
that you know there was the 50th
anniversary of the cape dorset print
collection last year if we look forward
the next 50 years how do you hope the
art scene here in Cape Dorset changes
for Carver's such as yourself that's a
good question but yeah I was it will
keep continue like it is doing now even
though the time changes today yeah the
life has changed to gay than before so
it's kind of hard to predict more hard
to tell my rush rush rush what are I can
see and then to know is there anything
else that you'd want people watching
this to know about you your life in Cape
Dorset or your work as a carver the
younger cars can you see more and
respect ya allah elder and that way they
wouldn't really loose doing carvings
like today yeah i was i was too if they
can listen and I'm sure they can listen
and one day I wanted to encourage the
more and share with them
how how the artwork the carbon above the
carbon this work or how it works without
Russians without rushing it Turner thank
you so much just terrific you work
quickly yeah